The 19th
most common question asked by the
non-Muslim Islam is that all the major
religions they speak good things. So
what is the difference between Islam and
the other religion? All religion says
don't rob. All religion says don't
cheat. All the religion says don't lie.
All the religion says that you should
not rape. Islam says the same. So what
is the difference between Islam and the
other religions? The difference between
Islam and the other religions. I do
agree that the major many of the major
things are common. Not to rob, not to
cheat,
not to rape. All religion says that.
Christianity says that, Judaism says
that, Hinduism says that, Islam says the
same. So what is the difference between
Islam and the other religions? The
difference between Islam and the other
religion is that Islam shows you a
practical way how to achieve that state
of goodness.
For example,
all major religions say that you should
not rob. Hinduism says that, Judaism
says that, Christianity says that, Islam
says the same. So what's the difference
between Islam and the other religion?
The difference is Islam shows you a
state in which people will not rob. For
example, Islam first talks about zakat.
Zakat is the third pillar of Islam that
every rich person who has a saving of
more than the nisab level, more than 85
g of gold, he or she should give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity. If every rich human being gives
charity, poverty will be eradicated from
this world.
There'll not be a single human being who
die of hunger. After that Allah says in
surah maida 5:38 as to the thief be it
male or female chop of his or her hand
as a punishment from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala say chopping of the hands in this
21st century Islam is a barbaric
religion it's a ruthless law but do you
know the country which we look up to
today one of the most advanced country
in the world America
Do you know it has one of the highest
rate of violence and theft in the
country? Do you know that according to
the National Survey of Victimization
Bureau of Justice called as US
Department of Justice in the year 2014
664,210
cases of robbery took place in USA.
If you divide this by 365,
you get a reply of 1,820
cases of robbery every day in USA. THAT
MEANS EVERY 1 SECOND 1.26 cases of
robberies taking place in USA. That's in
2014. Now it may have increased mean
every second more than one robbery. I'm
asking you the question if you implement
the Sharia in USA that every rich person
who has a saving of more than the nisab
level more than 85 g of gold he or she
should give 2.5% in charity after that
if anyone robs
chop off his or her hand I'm asking the
question will the rate of robbery and
theft in USA will it increase will it
remain the same or will it decrease
decrease very simple simple implement
the Sharia you get result. So that is
the reason I say Islam besides speaking
good things shows you a way how to
achieve that state of goodness.
YOU IMPLEMENT IT ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
YOU GET RESULTS.
Let me give you one more example.
All religions whether it be Hinduism,
Judaism, Christianity, Islam, they say
that you should molest a girl, you
should not rap woman.
The difference between Islam and the
other religion is Islam shows you a way
how to achieve a state which people will
not molest or rape a woman.
Islam talks about hijab. Besides before
talking about hijab for the woman, Allah
first speaks about the hijab for the man
in the Quran in surah nud chapter number
24 verse number 30 Allah says say to the
believing man that he should lower his
gaze and guard his modesty. Whenever a
man looks at a woman, if any brazen
thought, any unashamed thought comes, he
should lower his case.